Let's consider what we call
the window washer problem.
What we have is suspended
from some ceiling.
We have a pulley.
And the pulley is suspended
by a rope, which we're
going to call this string 3.
And we have a rope that is
wrapping around this pulley.
And then it wraps
around another pulley.
So this rope is going
And it's fixed to the ceiling.
And this is what we're
going to call string 1.
And then this string,
there's another string
that comes down to a platform.
And this one we're
going to call string 2.
And sitting on the
platform is a person.
So we have a person
sitting on the platform.
And that person is
pulling the rope down.
Now this is a very
complicated problem.
And it's a classic
example of how
do we choose systems so that we
can apply Newton's second law.
Now, one of the important
things we're going to do
is learn to see when we
choose a system what forces
are internal and external.
And that will enable us to
pick a very nice system, which
will make the analysis easy.
The way we'll do this is
will approach it in stages.
We'll first focus on the person,
the platform, and this pulley.
By the way, this is pulley
A. And this one is pulley B.
And let's use a symbol
P for the platform.
And we'll call this
a washer person.
And we're going to use the
symbol W for the person.
So what makes this
problem complicated
is all these different elements.
Now the first stage is
that what we're going to do
is we're going to
separately look
at the person, the
platform, and then
combine them into a system
of person and platform.
But notice, the rope is
connected to the platform.
So the next stages
will also consider
a system consisting of pulley
A, person, and the platform,
and the washer.
Now let's draw the
free body diagram.
Let's begin by drawing the free
body diagram on the washer.
So what do we have
on the washer?
The first thing to think
about is the string.
The washer is pulling
the string down.
So the string is
pulling the washer up.
So that's a force of
string 1 on the washer.
Now, there's also the
gravitational force m washer g.
And what we also have
to consider the fact
is that the person is
sitting on the platform.
So the platform is
pushing the person up.
And we'll call that a
normal force on the washer
due to the platform.
And those are the free body
diagram for the body diagram
on the washer.
Now let's focus on the platform.
So here, we'll
draw the platform.
And now let's look at the
forces on the platform.
Let's begin by looking for the
internal forces, the Newton's
third law pairs.
The platform is
pushing the person up.
The person is pushing
the platform down.
So we'll write that force
as N on the platform
due to the washer.
And immediately, let's just
circle this third law pair.
Now, string 2 is
pulling the platform up.
So let's draw that force.
We'll call that a tension
force in the string.
It's on the platform
due to string 2.
And finally, we have
the gravitational force
on the platform.
And that's our free body
diagram on the platform.
Now, you may have said, well,
why should I separate these
out?
Why didn't I just use the
person and the platform?
So let's draw that picture.
So now imagine underneath
this is a system consisting
of the person and the platform.
And I'll just draw
that system like that.
So what we're doing
is we're taking
these two separate
free body diagrams
and we're going to
combine them here.
And by Newton's third
law, all internal forces
should cancel in pairs.
So now let's separately
think about the forces
and see that that's the case.
Well, we have the
gravitational force
on the system, which is
the mass of the platform
plus the mass of
the washer times g.
We still have the string
pulling the person up
because the person is
pulling the string down.
So we still have the
force F1 on the washer.
That's string 1 on the washer.
And we still have the pulley,
the tension in string 2,
pulling it up.
So we still have the
force T2 on the platform.
Now, when you look at
this, what we're doing is
we're adding these two free
body diagrams together.
The internal forces now
are the normal force.
They're equal in magnitude,
opposite in direction.
So when you add them
together, they cancel.
And we're just left with
that, with that, with that,
and with that.
And so this is now
the combined system.
Now you might ask, why did
we not include the pulley?
Well, let's take a look at that.
So I'm going to draw the free
body diagram just on pulley
A. So let's draw pulley A.
Now what we have here is
the string on both sides
is pulling pulley A up.
And that's the
tension in string 1.
So what we have is-- I'm going
to call that tension in string
1, tension in string 1.
And just to alert you that keep
in mind that this force here
is the force of the
string on the person
and this too is also
tension in the string,
because this is our assumption
of a massless string.
So notice that everywhere in the
string, the tension is uniform.
So I'm just going to simplify
that by calling it T1.
What are the other
forces on the pulley?
Well, we're assuming that
these pulleys are massless.
And so there's no gravitational
force on the pulley.
And the only thing we have
is the string pulling--
is the tension in the string.
So now this is a
little bit different.
This is a force
on the pulley too.
So at the moment, let's
do something a little bit
different.
Let's consider our
system to be the string.
So it's pulley A. We
call that string 2.
That's our system.
So I modified that a little bit.
I just didn't consider
the pulley separately.
I considered the pulley and
the string as the system.
Then here the string is
pulling the platform up.
The platform therefore is
pulling the string down.
And once again, we
have a third law pair.
And so if I added
these two together,
then what I now have-- and this
is why this problem is kind
of complex-- we have pulley
A, string 2, platform P
and washer person.
And if we now add these
two systems together,
we have this complicated system.
But what are the
forces in this system?
Well, the rope is pulling it up.
The person was-- remember
we had this force, W1,
was the force of
string 1 on the washer.
That also was the tension
everywhere in the string.
So we have another T1 up.
These two forces
now cancel in pairs,
the internal forces there.
And so down, we just have
mass platform plus mass
of a washer times g.
And so you see in
this problem, if we
tried to treat
everything separate--
and I could have
even had the string
separate-- I have a lot
of free body diagram.
But when I think about what's
internal and what's external,
I can take these two
pieces, combine them here,
internal forces cancel in pairs.
I can draw these two separate
systems, again, combine them.
Internal forces cancel in pair.
And now I have this pulley A.
Now I can write down
Newton's second law.
So what I'll do next
is I'll introduce--
I still have to consider pulley
B. I'll use this as my system.
And I'll write down
Newton's second law.
And we'll be able to
solve this problem.